our shout out tonight to the reporter at
the Orange County Register in California
who is doggedly pursued the scandal of
sexual abuse at USA Swimming Orange
County's kind of epicenter of American
swimming this so this was really in our
backyard Scott Reed calls himself a
sports investigative reporter and over
the years we've done a lot of
investigative work on sexual abuse in
USA Gymnastics so this kind of blended
into swimming and he quickly realized
USA Swimming had a lot to hide it wasn't
easy it's a very closed Network it's a
good old boys network there's a couple a
handful of people that kind of run the
sport really powerful coaches and and if
you want to move up in the sport you
know you don't want to cross but Reed
took the time to listen to survivors
young women who had been abused but who
felt that USA Swimming was covering up
what happened you you asked these
survivors about what happened to him and
you're really the first person to really
give him give them an honest listen and
I think that was huge I think that was a
big part of our reporting but read
stories did not go over well with USA
Swimming and local readers who were part
of the swimming community lot of yeah a
lot of push back you know nasty emails
nasty calls Reed's most recent story
involved allegations brought against
swim coach Sean Hutchinson he was a
world championship team coach in 2009 he
was an Olympic team he's on Olympic team
coaching staffs and he ran this
high-profile Olympic prospect training
group in Fullerton California and there
was allegations at Hutchinson was
physically involved with a swimmer he
judged by name Arianna Cooper's who was
the world champion and world record
holder and 200 I am during that decade
he stole many things from me including
my swimming career my college experience
friendships my virginity and ultimately
my Olympic dream USA Swimming
investigated it eventually cleared him
of any wrongdoing the documents read
obtained told a much different story
what these documents show is that the
person that was hired to investigate
this matter a woman who was a former 20
was a 27 year veteran of the FBI
I was told not to interview certain
people without a louder interview
certain people and so what we found
where it was a deposition and some other
documents from this investigator that
proved that the this that the fine and
investigation was this was just totally
incorrect one more example of the power
and importance of investigative
journalism and staying on the story
dictator you have to do you have to do
what's best for the reader what's best
for people be writing about you know a
newspaper has responsibilities to its
readers to sometimes tell them what they
don't want to hear so I'll shut out
tonight to Scott Reed at the Orange
County Register that's our report for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here again next week good night